joining us now from Milwaukee the
hall-of-famer who'll be working with Fox
on the national championship series
let's say hello to John Smoltz
good morning John how are you good
morning dad I'm doing great yeah yeah
well it's good to have you on how's
morale in Milwaukee what's what's the
feeling you get out on the street there
John ah gloves in a hat it's really cold
that's the feeling I got because it was
40 degrees difference from Atlanta to
Milwaukee but you know I think
everything here for the first time
you're gonna see a weekend where maybe
the Packers are second fiddle to the
Milwaukee Brewers at this time of the
year and that hasn't happened in a long
time
who do you expect to win this series you
know I think what people expect usually
this time of year doesn't always happen
but it would be the Dodgers just from
the standpoint of what they did last
year and where they are now with their
roster and the changes they made but you
know what makes baseball so unique is
that storylines or markets people assume
you know because you're in a certain
region of the country
I think the Brewers have something
pretty special going with 11 in a row
timing is everything the way that
they've gone about it I think this
series has the makings of a if you're a
strategy guru if you're a if you'd like
to see moves and certain things that
counteract the strengths of another team
then you're gonna like this
this series of far as how many guys are
gonna play the Milwaukee as far as
pitchers go there's gonna be a lot of
pitchers but your big concern with the
Dodgers I think the the concern would be
that if it got into a bullpen matchup
game if it goit a I think for the first
time you know Milwaukee has a better
bullpen and the Dodgers last year you
know had a really good bullpen that they
went to a lot this year I think you're
gonna see the starters be like they were
down the stretch more counted on and
more
moaning spits I've always maintained you
know this might be the exception this
year I've always said that the team that
can utilize their starters more and the
long-run has a better chance to win it
all
but what Milwaukee did in the short
series winning three games they were
able to have that formula proved
successful so if they can continue to do
that and win an extraordinary x' and not
have serious drag on then I think they
got a great chance
the Dodgers lineup with relentless their
bench is as good as anybody so they can
mix and match it's just a matter of how
does Dave Roberts stay patient and not
right away when you know they make a lot
of changes and go to the bullpen it's
got to pick and choose where he's going
to use guys off the bench
Clayton Clayton Kershaw's regular season
ER a is the lowest among pitchers with
at least 200 starts since 1920 his four
point career postseason er a is the
second highest among those with at least
15 starts second second only to CC
Sabathia did you see anything in his
last start that would kind of put your
fears to rest if you're a Dodger fan of
what you expect from Clayton Kershaw who
does pitch well at Miller Park yeah you
know the perception of course has been
he had those four kind of crazy games I
think three of them against st. Louis in
the last year's game against the Astros
that might stick out but the Dodgers of
won ten of his last eleven or ten of his
last 12 postseason starts so to me that
that that speaks to how he has adjusted
and last game he showed that he can
pitch without 95 he only struck out one
guy which is like one of the first times
in a long time that he's ever done that
if ever and I think this series knowing
that he has been rested and that he has
been taken care of as he doesn't have to
be the Bulldog all year look his mindset
still give me the ball I'm the best
pitcher in the universe that's what you
got to have but the team has recognized
that you know the depth of the rotate
allows them to not have to have kershaw
come on three days rest like you did a
lot of times in those past past post
season so I maintain that's in the
rearview mirror for him and
statistically I think you'll see that
come down and be more reflective of his
regular season
Fox Sports opens its coverage to the
national championship series between the
Dodgers Brewers tonight from Miller Park
pregame will be at 7:00 Eastern on Fox
Sports one game coverage at 8:00 Eastern
on Fox Sports one Jill buck John and Ken
Rosenthal Tom Verducci will be there on
the call Game two from Milwaukee or
Saturday afternoon at 4:00 live on Fox
Network how do you not let ego factor in
when you're on the mound it can be hard
especially when you start thinking about
let's just say last series
what Kershaw doing start Game one you
know there are things that in this game
that when you have a reputation or when
you are the best pitcher in baseball for
the last 10 11 years and guys in your
club you know stuff is starting to be a
little bit better if you'd better look
to me I think what Clayton represents is
everything we want a player to represent
so at times an organization may have to
have conversations or communication
since with your star player but the ego
on the mound has got to be there in the
ability to think that you are better
than anybody that steps in the plate but
you can't allow it to have such a chip
on your shoulder and that's easier said
that done when you may be passed over or
somebody else might be the hotter
pitcher at the time and that's just a
unique situation that the Dodgers have
have so many good pictures that they get
to line it up the way they get to line
it up Christian Yelich is 9 for 17
against Kershaw
so he's batting 529 there were certain
guys that had your number do you change
anything because of that success that
they have against you
yeah I think you know the tree if it
were the regular season you you look at
this certainly they're gonna look at all
the video he's gonna look at everything
he's gonna look at things that you did
the past if you didn't like and make
certain adjustments but the post season
is always a different animal but
traditionally you are going the first
thing you're going to do is look to
something different you want it you want
to show the hit or something different
you you want to be able to make the
necessary adjustment but the biggest
thing is it is a different stage so this
would be the first time they face each
other in the post season and that that
in that in and of itself resets the
clock but as soon as he gets a hit your
memory starts kicking back in and you
start getting frustrated because of the
past success and it's not really a small
sample size so that's that's why you
have to make changes and as a pitcher
and then vice versa if you've had a lot
of success you don't really want to make
a lot of changes you want to see what
the hitters gonna do first so I love and
miss the cat-and-mouse games especially
in the postseason because you're just
reading the body and the aggressiveness
of a hitter at this time of the year to
determine how you want to attack them I
felt like any guy in the postseason that
wanted to be the hero at the plate or
aggressive I was gonna be successful
100% of the time but if he was more
towards like I'll take my walk and
patient then it was a battle but that's
what you're trying to figure out in a
postseason you want guys aggressive you
want each guy standing in the plate want
to hit a home or trying to be the hero
for their team and and let the moment
get too big
I talked to Dave Roberts about this I
said you rely on the homerun too much
and he said no we rely on that a lot but
we did walk 27 times in the National
League divisional series I looked at the
Yankees and I thought that they were
built for the regular season not the
postseason and you know this better than
anybody being able to come up with that
big hit or just something small moving a
runner over getting a runner in from
third it just didn't feel like the
Yankees were built that way you know we
see a lot of teams that are like this
though John
so I wonder where we're there there is a
place for that in baseball and how
important and I feel like it there's
something going to happen in this
postseason whether it's the championship
series or the World Series we're
something small will decide who wins it
all I really believe that and we get
caught up in strikeouts in homeruns and
it still feels like there's nuance here
that you know some of these teams don't
factor in your thoughts on them
absolutely no absolutely and I've gone
back 10 years I mean eventually if
everyone starts flying closer to the
same type of baseball someone's going to
win the World Series leading the league
in the home runs but it rarely happens I
mean you got to go back forever
that you got teams that lead the league
in homeruns and are up there and
strikeouts it just it just doesn't bode
well for a championship run but if you
do take your walks and you get on base
and you put pressure on the pitchers you
have a better chance look last year was
a great example of the Houston Astros
getting those strikeouts making the
contact doing the little things that's
what allows them to win the World Series
now what's gonna always stand out is the
big home runs you know springers home
runs home runs still a reign king in our
game from a standpoint of instant runs
and they're just harder or typically
they were harder to come by in the
postseason because you're facing elite
pitchers but when every guy in the
lineup now or the potential of guys
hitting home runs are in the lineups
you're gonna run into more of those so
that's gonna still stick out but I still
totally agree with you that the team
with the least amount of selfish at-bats
and I'm talking about a selfish if that
to me is defined as running around third
less than two outs and you're still
trying to hit a home run when the
infields back and all you got to do is
hit a ground ball to get the game closer
or tie it up you know those are the
things that if you still have too many
of those selfish bats in your club
you're gonna have to be so much better
than the other team to win because
you're given you're just not putting
yourself in the best situation so I
totally totally agree with that
statement and and as time goes on we'll
see if a team can defy that on a year
where they
win it all and they you know they led
the postseason and strikeouts and they
let the postseason and it just it it's
going to come down to that and and
that's what I'm always looking forward
to see which player is able to do that
or which team is able to do that better
good to talk to you John have fun
tonight and we'll catch up with you soon
thank you you got a dad that's a John
Smoltz Hall of Famer and working for Fox
as their baseball analyst in the
postseason coverage tonight 7:00 Eastern
on Fox Sports 1
and then the game at 8 o'clock on Fox
Sports 1 Joe Buck John Smoltz Kenny
Rosenthal Tom Verducci and then game 2
will be Saturday afternoon at 4:00 on
Fox for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]